joining us now presidential candidate
Nikki Haley governor Ambassador Kat I
don't know what to call you anymore I I
think U.N Ambassador is low on the list
uh good to see you thank you good to see
you it's Nikki those are moments in time
okay all right when you're Joe Biden and
all of a sudden you lose uh let's see
Maureen Dowd David Ignatius liberal Joe
um you're losing James Carville David
Axelrod and uh van Jones and even kind
of losing Nancy Pelosi what what a tepid
comment about the President and Vice
President in that interview she gave
last week is it over for them
I think they know they're in trouble and
look you can say that the economy is
doing great but people are struggling
when they go to the grocery store when
they go to the gas station they see it
with crime on the streets they see it
with an open border they see it with the
lack of transparency in schools in which
you know they're wanting parents to turn
over their kids to the custody of
teachers unions it's a problem and he
knows it but the reality is he's trying
to just win this election so that Kamala
Harris can be in office that's who we're
really running against but it doesn't
matter whether it's Joe Biden it doesn't
matter if it's Kamala Harris we're going
to wipe them out without any question
you saw that a couple weeks ago a Biden
strategist said that the number one
person they didn't want to go up against
in a general election was me and there's
a reason because they know that we'd
take care of them pretty quick you know
if if you look at the borders we're
going to have what eight million illegal
immigrants in three years under Joe
Biden that's out of control crime you're
right is out of control look at gas now
four dollars a gallon and going higher
you know we're going to be over a
hundred dollars a barrel for gasoline I
can't think and never mind Russia and
China and giving billions of dollars to
Iranian mullers ransom for hostages I
don't see a single policy that Joe is
implementing that's working and I'm
trying to be objective if he did one
thing I would tell you I can't think of
one
well I mean look Sean I mean he gave his
entire speech to the world the one that
you wait on every year where you tell
the world where America is going and
what did he talk about climate change he
didn't talk about the fact that China's
buying up our farmland or stealing
intellectual property or putting a spy
center off our Coast in Cuba he didn't
talk about a Chinese spy balloon going
overhead or the fact that they've killed
enough Americans with fentanyl than the
Iraq Afghanistan or Vietnam Wars
combined no he talked about climate
change and he talked about China being a
competitor and you know I'll tell you if
you do all that China's not a competitor
they've been preparing for war with us
for years and Joe Biden is asleep at the
wheel he doesn't get it the American
people are smarter than this they see
that he doesn't get it and it is time
for a new generational leader
Republicans have lost the last seven out
of eight popular votes for president
it's time for us to change that we
should want to win the majority of
Americans I'm going to make sure we do
that and we're going to make sure that
Joe Biden and Kamala Harris are out of
office can you imagine if I wanted to go
to China and buy thousands and thousands
of Acres of Farmland Ranch land land
near their military installations the
way that's happening in this country
that would never happen they're not that
stupid why is America allowing this to
happen the the aggressive nature against
our fighter jets and international
Aerospace are ships in international
waterways no responsibility for covid
spy balloons intellectual property theft
unfair Trade Practices threatening and
saber rattling Taiwan with their you
know uh geopolitical Ambitions on
display almost every day and and Joe
does nothing he says he wants to partner
with them and this is nothing new and
frankly we've got to look at Republicans
and democrats for this Sean
um Trump did a great job of focusing on
Chinese trade but he did nothing about
the Farmland he did nothing about the
fentanyl he did nothing about the
stealing of intellectual properties we
have start we've got to start showing
our enemies that we're on to them and we
need to start doing things right we need
to not only stop China from buying
Farmland we need to take back what
they've already gotten we need to tell
universities you either take Chinese
money or you take American money but the
days of taking both are over we need to
tell China will end all normal trade
relations until you stop killing
Americans and we need to remember that a
strong military doesn't start War strong
militaries prevent Wars and it's time
that we modernize our military so that
our enemies know that we're serious and
that we're not going to let anything
happen to hurt Americans uh the abortion
issue you brought this up in the last
debate we do have less than a minute but
what is your message to Republicans
around the country especially if they
want to win and swings States I would
argue have played a big role in the 2022
midterms your thoughts quit demonizing
the issue humanize the issue bring
people together on the fact that we have
to save as many babies as we can and
support as many moms as we can you can't
do that by lying to the American people
you have to understand that any law has
to have a majority of the house 60
Senate votes and a signature of a
president we haven't had 60 Republicans
in over a hundred years we might have 45
pro-life Senators so let's start
humanizing this issue and start bringing
people together for the good of saving
babies and people have to understand
it's now a state issue it really isn't a
federal issue right now for the people
all right uh Governor Nikki Haley thank
you for being with us appreciate it hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else